Adrian whoa turn around ski did a great
job is always with his tweets last night
as it plays out in real I wish we had
more situations like that in sports
where you had those kind of
announcements where somebody is gonna
retire step down or announce somebody's
getting fired
Woods joins us now how surprised were
you was last night yeah I think like
everybody else shocked it especially the
manner in which Magic Johnson did it if
you would have told me that he's gonna
bail on the job because he just doesn't
want to do all that it entails I don't
think that would have been surprising to
anybody but to do it the way he did it
to publicly announce it before he'd even
told gd+ of his intentions or anybody
else at that level of the organization
was shocking especially when you
believed and he I think essentially
confirmed that he was on his way to fire
Luke Walton today and now all of a
sudden Luke Walton survives Magic's out
and Luke might be on the firmest ground
among you know their high profile high
ranking basketball people there
when did it start to go wrong well I
think you know the Lakers did a good job
but like their earlier first draft and
you know listen everyone can pick at the
Lonzo ball at number two it's like at a
time
I didn't hear a lot of criticism of it
even around the NBA I think you go back
to that when they did make the trade for
Paul George and they could have traded
that pick or Brandon Ingram and gotten
Paul George in the door thinking they
were going to get him in free agency it
didn't happen you know those were
certain certainly missteps free agency
last summer the kind of players they
brought in to play with LeBron those
were mistakes but I think bigger picture
organizationally magic never committed
to doing the job the way you need to do
it which is to be fully immersed putting
in the time it is a big job and it's not
something you can do part-time he wasn't
around a lot he wasn't in the facility a
great deal he would be off traveling
he'd be attending to his other business
he wasn't out scouting and so
those things all impact like the
decisions you make over time and then
things start to get away from you do you
think that magic wanted to get rid of
Luke and was told he can't fire him and
then that might have been the last straw
like something it feels like had to
happen where I mean that's an emotional
moment their decision yesterday yeah III
don't think he was told that Dan I think
he had the ability to make that change
if you're Magic Johnson and you're
looking down the road here as to what's
coming summer free agency the Lakers
right now are not a frontrunner for any
of the big free agents that doesn't mean
they won't get one but like they had
great confidence they were going to get
LeBron James they don't have that right
now among other big free agents in fact
some of the others who are available
prefer the Clippers situation to the
Lakers and it speaks to ownership
management how you run things those
things that's what appeals more than
ever to free agents like if the Lakers
are run well if they're run from top to
bottom in like an exemplary way you
can't beat them but if it's going to
look like this you can you can beat them
in July you can go on free agency and
just the destination of the Lakers and
the banners in the history that's not
enough alone but if you have the thing
rolling just like if that was the case
with the Knicks you would never beat
those guys in free agency but they've
been so poorly run for so long you've
seen them not be able to sustain any
success where did the Lakers stand with
Anthony Davis yeah you know they're one
of you know a ton of teams who probably
love to trade for him but but one who
you know they had confidence that if
they traded for him that he would resign
with them I don't know today where that
stands
New Orleans hasn't hired a new GM yet
and they've and once they do then you'll
have somebody who will sort of chart a
new course for them but he's not a free
agents of 2020 and right now that feels
like a long time away for this Lake
organization
and you're looking at LeBron James at
what will he be 35 years old by the time
Anthony Davis could be a free agent and
walk in the door and so if Davis gets
traded somewhere else he could decide to
resign and stay there so they they can't
as an organization just sit around and
wait for Anthony Davis to come like
they've got to fix things address things
and they've got to bring themselves into
2019 and how successful organizations
are set up and run and that's Jeanne
buses responsibility she hired Magic
Johnson if you were let's say you took
off your media hat and you were going to
advise the Lakers what would you tell
them today what would you tell Jeannie
bust today I would tell them to call I
would tell them to reach out to Bob
Meyers in Golden State to RC Buford in
San Antonio to executives of that tilt
and find out how attractive the Lakers
are to the best team builders in the NBA
and and offer a scenario where they can
come in with complete control autonomy
it with the way they want to do it and
then get out of their way and I think
they would find and I'm not saying
necessarily would those to a particular
I don't know if those two would be
interested but they need to start that's
how they have any thinking there are
other we know who they are you know who
they are then there are other like
really high performing executives in the
league who believe that the Lakers
if run correctly it's a monster and and
would love to get their hands on that
that platform and all in the history and
what it would mean to win in LA and the
Lakers haven't done that they promoted
from within
now when Quentin was Jerry West it was
the best of both worlds it was an iconic
Laker figure who also was an iconic
league executive and his in his you know
heyday and running the Lakers but magic
was put in there as largely a ceremonial
figure he hadn't done the job they need
to go out and if somebody has Laker ties
and they're the best candidate fine but
they
need to go out and find the best people
in the NBA and try to get them on the
Lakers like that's how it works
he's Adrian will general ski ESPN senior
NBA insider I said this at the time so
it's not revisionist history that when
it felt like Jerry West wanted to end
his career with the Lakers that he was
sort of not begging but you know that
that there was that possibility or he'd
be open to that possibility and I said
how could you pass up that opportunity
to still bring him in what was that a
realistic scenario that Jerry West could
have come back a couple of years ago and
we would have it we would be talking
about something different today well
listen juries I mean he's done is I
don't I'm Sadie Warner he's in his 80s
he's yeah he's not going to be here he's
not a day-to-day GM that's how what he
didn't go on the states how he does the
Clippers he's a consultant he's around
to to give some thoughts there's
obviously a great deal to learn from
Jerry was for any front office but they
need somebody who they need Jerry west
from when he was in you know that's a
that's not a job Jerry's or a role that
he I think has been looking for hey I'm
gonna be the day-to-day guy and go to
the Ohio Valley Conference tournament
the Cisco John Moran like that's not
what he's doing now and so but that's
what you need someone do now as Jerry
West as a compliment to that they have
used him perfectly with the Clippers
they have built this really good
front-office
Lawrence Frank and michael winger and
Steve Ballmer at the top and you seen in
18 months or less in two years the way
they set themselves up for the future
with draft picks with caps faced with
really good role players that star
players might want to play with and an
owner and Steve Ballmer has figured this
thing out pretty quick like you can put
yourself in position and then you bring
Jerry West into that mix yeah and he
adds an element that that has helped
them but the Lakers have to find that
one you know they need to find their
star executive who's you know in his
prime doing the job and then maybe you
add a Jerry West in then it sounds
strange though loads that you know I
said this and even when I say it it
sounds strange that I would rather have
the Clippers future than the Lakers
future
it's not even close and you see it in
New York with Brooklyn the way Brooklyn
has run their organization first the
Knicks that doesn't mean the Knicks
aren't just going to end up getting a
couple big free agents that maybe they
do but you're seeing if if you run your
organization right and you put the right
people there you can make yourself
attractive especially in a market like
LA or New York like you're gonna change
the perception of yourself with players
relatively quickly the Clippers have
done that and the Nets have done that
was it a real possibility that Jeanie
buss looked at trading LeBron or at
least it was put on her table or her
desk do you know that possibility I I
don't know the answer to that and I I
just I don't think you trade for LeBron
James and then decide to move him before
the first trade deadline like you know
there's always moments of frustration
people have and and with something set
in and frustration one day I don't know
but to me there's always a big
difference I hear some things set around
the league that if I you know we've like
an hour later people feel differently
just like any of us when you lose your
cool I I don't and I don't even know if
that was a scenario but but they didn't
sign LeBron James to just trade them
well I said on the air than if I could
trade LeBron and get Anthony Davis then
I would do that not everybody agreed
with me but I said I got a better chance
of landing free agents with Anthony
Davis and as I move forward I have a
star who's you know in his mid 20s that
that I I'm better prepared for long-term
success than I am with LeBron in there
yeah I think just because of their ages
that's accurate but it's not really a
trade that's you you know somebody would
have interest in it's just but but
you're right like I just think because
of the age of the two players right 25
and 34 you'd probably say that with
almost any star of that caliber but yeah
I was also curious about this that it
feels like you're honest is going to be
the MVP and like we've almost gotten
bored with triple-doubles and you know
Harden getting 50 and 15 and a night
that if this was reversed and Yanis won
the
b.p last year who would win the MVP this
year in your opinion it's a good
question dan I I think it seems like
it's going to be a very close vote I I
think you honest gonna win it just
because it's not it yeah I think Yanis
is a very I think people he's very
likeable he there's an earnestness about
him that appeals to people I think
there's some intangibles there beyond
numbers that that really boost his
candidacy and I'm not saying people
don't feel that way about James Harden
but you know that they're both you can
make you can make a case for either guy
without tearing the other down there
they're both having MVP seasons there's
no wrong answer like you like if
somebody votes for one or the other they
were both right but but obviously only
one guys don't win and then you got the
whole triple-double thing that everybody
was mesmerised by that my god he's gonna
average a triple-double Russell
Westbrook and then all of a sudden he's
done it three years in a row and it's
not a big deal anymore that we quickly
move on from these stories here harden
putting up these unbelievable nights
it's like yeah okay oh did you see the
Greek freak the Bucks have the best
record in basketball and it's like
there's your news story here's the new
shiny thing and that feels like that's
how this votes gonna go yeah no
absolutely and I think the fact that you
know like you're splitting hairs if you
say he's a two-way player right he's
dominant on both ends of the floor
that's a place we were splitting hairs
but yeah the numbers and we see it you
just said and the numbers have we've
seen this explosion and offensive
numbers and players you've never heard
of are getting back-to-back triple
doubles right it just doesn't it doesn't
mean much to people in that and that's
not that the minute I'm not saying it's
easy but we just were seeing it done by
players people don't even know who they
are and and this guy's gotten you know
back-to-back triple doubles and so I
think it's it's diluted the impact of it
great stuff I know you've been busy
great stuff last night we appreciate
your time as always watch thanks for
having me as always that's a Adrian
woods NeuroSky
ESPN senior NBA insider for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app